thank you very much to my brave
volunteers really love it when people
are happy to come up front and whether
they write all their role put their
rights up here so we can all discuss it
and learn so let's go through them one
at a time and see what's going on here
sixty lollies and I was in total pig
Tommy two bits of them who agrees with
36 as to how many of their pens up
straight kids up I can't like it they
keep us down but don't hold hands now
I think 36 is not the first answer I bet
a lot of people would renown or at least
the first piece of working what might be
a common other answer but you could
write based on discussion yet Hill 25 24
now 24 I'm willing to put somebody down
there's a few of you who have put doubt
24 as your honor okay now 24 is not a
crazy answer weirdest 24 come from in
the question area very good so 24 that's
actually I will do the work here maybe
you can follow with me if you didn't do
a key is 60 times 2 over 5 right or I
could write it the other way round
because we know modification you can
change the order it's awkward so from
here what would you like me to do in
terms of the working like how can I make
that a bit simple yeah plastic so 5
divided by 60 is 12 and the 12 times 2
gives you the 24 the 2014 important
number it's the number of lollies that I
ate but the question is asking something
else isn't it it's ask me how many are
still left right so this shows the
importance of the question what's it
really asking you had 36 is perfect all
right let's have a look at this next one
yeah I've got glad to hear from the boy
what have you think of it yeah different
who's got a different answer
not many who's going to say that sir
okay so we've got a few sort of all the
way across
disagrees so how are we going to dissect
whether this is right or volved I've
been already asleep part of this looks
good to me part of this looks good
namely that 3 right how can I tell so
quickly we aren't even putting pizza
board paper that the three is right okay
so I see the one of the two and I
noticed that one plus two is three now
that's the stuff that's actually not the
finish right if for instance I changed
this question a little bit suppose I
changed it to one and nine tens plus two
and a quarter the same guaranteed does
it apply why not you're not going to get
up with a three and something you get up
with a four and something why yeah for
you to do 1 plus 2 to get 3 yeah very
good so what you have they wanted to
make up they do come together to be 3
but then when you put these guys
together they end up being bigger than 1
right so therefore you've got the 3 we
started with the extra bits that hang on
and so that's why this is going to be a
bigger number but have a look at the
actual question we've got look at those
factors there they're pretty small yeah
they both fit underneath one so then how
can I actually work out what the answer
is
from those fractions do we look at those
bits together okay so this is what I'm
looking here I'm just thinking about the
fractions now how am I going to combine
these two fractions can someone give me
a suggestion
okay so I want to comment it over - it
seems quite a lot what would be the
smallest common denominator you can come
up with this for this pair of numbers
yeah give me 20 very good now our first
colors what's this morning four more
times ten
but twenties even better isn't it the
multiples of ten are ten twenty thirty
the multiples of four are 4 8 12 16 20
BAM I've got a common one
okay so what will this fracture be if I
turn it to over 20 instead of over 10
what will it become 6 xx perfect 6 over
20 when I turn this one into over 20
what will it become yeah very good so
you can see to go from this fraction to
this one which is equivalent I multiply
the top and the bottom by 5 yeah you see
it okay so this looks perfect common
denominators what's that equal to
very good 6 plus 5 and the denominators
Bitcoin can we simplify this fraction at
all it's kind of stocky isn't it in fact
one of the reason why you know you can't
sit fight is because 11 is a special
kind of number we looked at in the
alcohol numbers [ __ ] dinner remember
starts with a pain I said yeah buddy
it's quite right you can't divide 11 by
anything except for 11 on one so baby
its prime in the 20s 9 you sort of
started so therefore I'm going to modify
this air type just the team you get I'm
gonna change this 3 over 5 into 11 over
20 which I won't point is quite close to
3 over 5 but they're off by the room
okay are you happy with that one how
about Christian 3 do we gave a thumbs up
to 13 over 5 yeah I want going through
that because again it's the same process
called the Donora just compare now this
last one this lost one who agrees a
sneaks yeah you see a few heads up yeah
okay
does anyone disagree have a different
answer okay that's interesting because I
have a different answer now let me try
and explain why my answer is humble be
different if I agree with the number one
over six right but let's come back to
this do you remember when we did the
topic of integers do you remember that
which is numbers that can be above or
below numbers with Direction rights
that's why pulling the directed numbers
we know how to do this big take away
small it's three but with integers we
saw you can do it the other way around
right so what does this e yes it's
negative three so therefore over here
you see I've got the same thing right
small takeaway beam so Aaron join it
help me out what's gonna be different
yeah so well that's all it's missing the
one over six is thumbs up but it's
actually a negative there right because
it's a smaller than by taking away a
bigger number so just like here's a
small take away B you're gonna end up
with a name that makes sense